The only genotype that this grandfather could
be, is actually the heterozygous genotype, plus minus.
Now what's the reasoning behind this? Well
we know, right off the bat, that because
it's a dominant trait, and he's affected,
that he can't be homozygous recessive, the minus
minus. Because this scenario is the normal height
or the unaffected individual. We know he's affected,
so he can't be that, but now the question
is we know he has at least one achondroplasia
allele, one of the plus alleles, but how do
we know if he has one or two, if he's
homozygous or heterozygous? And for that answer we're going to
look at his children. specific in the all the factors
is shown yes to reachout the two factors one
another factorsif he is in fact come this side dominate
for the cause we would expect all the
children is infact one of these Dominant alleles. But
the fact that his son is unaffected means
that his son did not get a dominant allele.
We know that the mother, obviously didn't give
him a dominant allele. And the father couldn't have
given him a dominant allele because he's unaffected.
This must mean that he has two unaffected alleles.
And one of them came from the
father, which means the father must be heterozygous.